FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thanks for coming
to one of the latest of our
talks for our NASA series.
Today we have Dr.
Dave Korsmeyer.
Am I saying it correctly?
He mentioned when we
walked in that he probably
used to work with 20
to 30 current Googlers.
So you may know him already.
Dave is the director of
engineering at NASA Ames.
He was previously the chief of
NASA Ames Intelligent Systems
Division.
He led the near-Earth object
mission concept studies
for NASA, directly supported
President Obama's 2009
human space flight review, and
was part of the human space
flight architecture
teams technology panel.
Dave received his BS in
aerospace engineering
from Penn State,
his MS and Ph.D.
in astrodynamics from the
University of Texas at Austin.
We got some fans back here.
That's a lot of schooling.
DAVE KORSMEYER:
Couldn't get enough.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Dave is also
a Sloan fellow with a master's
in Business Management
from Stanford Graduate
School of Business.
Without further ado,
here is Dave Korsmeyer.
After, we're going to leave
some time for questions.
And we do ask that you use
the microphone over here when
you ask the question, so people
on the live stream can hear.
Thank you.
DAVE KORSMEYER: Thank you, Mary.
Appreciate it.
Yeah, I am addicted
to schooling.
So just that's my own personal
foible, with apologies.
Thanks everybody,
for showing up.
I'm either your afternoon, after
lunch talk or your after lunch
nap.
If you're going to
nap, do it quietly.
Drool with the
best of intentions.
What I'm going to talk
to you about today
is these little
babies, to some degree.
And let's start, because
I find hands-on stuff
gives you something to do.
Take a look at these,
pass them around,
and then occasionally
listen to what I'm saying.
What's going on is actually
a disruption in my industry.
My industry is aerospace, is
space missions in particular.
And what we've got is
we've got a new-- not so
new, but new to NASA form
factor called CubeSats.
And what exactly is it CubeSat?
We used to call them nanosats.
And then that just
didn't sound cool enough,
so everybody calls
them CubeSats.
It actually came out as
a university concept.
Stanford and Cal
Poly came up with it.
1U is a 10 centimeter
by 10 centimeter
by 10 centimeter cube.
Think four inches square, for
those of you still on imperial.
And that qualifies
as a U, a unit.
So if you look on
your left, you got 1U.
That's what you're
holding right now.
And 3U is linear, three
of them put together.
6U is a 2 by 3 by 1 box.
Think of a toaster oven.
Those are the common
denominator sizes
for what we call
CubeSats these days.
So even though a 6U is 6U,
we still call it a CubeSat.
You see why I like
nanosat, but I'm not
the guy that gets
to set these things.
You'll notice as you
pass these around
also, the weight the comparable
weight of these things--
the one over here on
the side is probably
about a full kilo and a half.
That's probably about 500 grams.
So the range of these is, we'll
pack them as dense as we can,
because it is actually the
volume that is constraining us.
And I'll tell you a little bit
why about that in a minute.
So when you think of NASA and
you think of mission types,
I came across this analogy
and I kind of like it.
There's three types.
There's the grandfather
clock, which is big and fancy,
elegant, expansive, handcrafted.
You have to have a team of
experts, takes years to build,
takes experts to repair.
Think of the International
Space Station.
Manned missions are like that.
We can do them.
They're beautiful.
They're phenomenal.
Everyone wants them
in their house.
Few people can afford it.
Then we get Swiss clocks.
Those are those cool things that
sit on your parents' mantle.
They're nice.
They're very expensive.
They're handcrafted, built by
a bunch of really sharp people
off in Switzerland,
do great things.
They also are very
expensive, but are
smaller and more efficient.
Think of our robotic science.
Think of the Mars
Rovers for that.
Now that traditionally has been
what NASA has been able to do.
That's what we do.
There is again, this disruption.
We're getting into
the point where
the available commercial-grade,
consumer-grade technologies are
able to fulfill space
missions for us, now
at a much greatly
reduced cost, which
means we can do a
lot more of them.
And that's the quartz watches.
Think the Swatch.
If you guys are young or
old enough to remember that,
I do, unfortunately.
Mass-produced.
Now I know nobody has watches.
I could have said
the cell phone.
It would have been just fine.
I probably will change it out.
But they have actually much
more limited functionality,
where the functionality
is enabled
on software versus
actual hardware.
And you can mass-produce
them to some degree,
or they are availably made out
of mass-produced components.
And that's what CubeSats are.
And that's what
they're supposed to be.
And NASA is coming
to terms with,
what are we going
to do with that?
Because it's a different
model, a different perspective
for how we've done space
exploration in the past.
One of the things
we have done is
we've created a thing called
the CubeSat Launch Initiative.
This actually started as an
educational outreach model
where, as I said,
this form factor
came out of the
university basis.
Sounds good.
You're going to
build a satellite.
Wonderful!
You put that together
in some senior design
class or graduate degree
class, or whatever you've done.
Now what?
How do you get it into space?
Are you going to build
your own launch vehicle?
OK.
That's still a little bit
harder than the average bear
can pull off.
So what happens is, it
turns out that there's
a bunch of agencies,
DoD being one,
NASA being a huge one
are intelligent agencies
and commercial launch that
launch into space all the time.
There's launches every
couple weeks, actually.
If you go online, you
can just Google it
and you'll see that
there literally
are launches all the time.
The interesting thing
about those launches
is they aren't full.
Why?
Because you're designing
these big spacecraft,
either commercial
telecom bird that's
relaying the internet
around or dish or whatever,
or exploration missions
that we've got on NASA,
and you design with a 10%
or 15% percent margin.
Because you really don't
know what's going to happen.
So what happens when you've
delivered to the pad,
you end up and you've
got this big faring,
and you've got this
little teeny spacecraft.
And you've got this
big launch rocket.
little teeny spacecraft.
And you probably got a
couple tens to hundreds
to thousands of
kilograms of extra mass
you could throw into space, and
several cubic meters of space
you could throw into
space-- of volume,
I mean, you could
throw up into space.
So what they came up with was
the idea that by standardizing
on this form factor, you
could create little dispensers
that you would mount
in the launch vehicles
and they would be called
secondary payloads.
And so you would just show up.
The big launcher would
show up, the big spacecraft
would show up, and
the university student
would show up with
their small satellite
and say, OK-- not literally the
day of, but six months ahead,
say-- and say, OK,
I want to ride.
I know mine is this
size, is this volume,
behaves in this way, and you
can stick it in your launcher.
And after you deploy
the main satellite,
you can pop this off.
So it's a free ride.
That worked so well, this
CubeSat Launch Initiative
has basically started signing
up people started in 2009,
and has been
progressively going.
As I said, it's a simple matter
of, you design the spacecraft,
you build it, this dispenser
here is called a peapod.
It can handle up to
three-- this one right here
can handle up to
three 1U CubeSats.
The 1U CubeSats are just that.
They're kind of toys.
By the time you put
in any instrumentation
or any actual tools that are
of value to the engineering
or science or
technological community,
you really need like
3U of volume, which is,
say, a small toaster.
And we're getting to a
point where we're commonly
flying 6U of volume,
which is a toaster oven.
So you put it in the known
dispenser, which has already
got all the mountings,
you launch it off.
It deploys once in space.
And then students
or a NASA center
can communicate
with the spacecraft
and get the science or
technology demonstration
or engineering done.
It became a very viable model.
Now what happened is the
students and universities
started doing that and
were doing great stuff.
They were getting really good
technical papers out of it.
And frankly, the
NASA guys said, hey,
there's something going on here.
Look at all these people
that are making use of it.
We've got from 2009
to 2014, we did,
I think, six CLSI selections.
And we made 114 selections for
114 different satellite systems
at universities that are going
to deploy, and lined them up
and told them when
they're going to fly.
And so they're off and running.
NASA decided, well, there's
something wrong with that.
We're missing out.
Because look at the numbers.
There's a huge number
of proposals, 150,
but we select over
2/3 of them, 109.
We've only flown a fifth of
them right now, say, or a third
of those selected, 34, and
we've got another 14 manifested.
So there's a lot coming online.
There's a lot happening.
And we realized that
we're not alone.
This is a different view.
Again, forgive.
It's a NASA chart, so
there's acronyms everywhere.
Take the following out of it.
The rightmost column
here is the number
of CubeSats being deployed as
a secondary, as extra volume
on a mainline mission.
The CLSI moniker here are the
ones that NASA helped sponsor.
The other ones, like, say
International Space Station
which has got NanoRacks, a
commercial company that kind of
spun out of doing
some NASA business now
launches 28 CubeSats a pop.
Actually, more than 28.
48 CubeSats a pop
on their dispenser
up off of the International
Space Station.
So there's a huge volume that
doesn't come through NASA.
It goes up through other
means on other launch vehicles
and does excellent work.
Now again, what
does this give you?
Why would NASA care about
something like this?
It's supposed to be an
educational activity.
Something that trains up
engineers and scientists.
It's STEM.
Why does NASA care?
Well, turns out we
stumbled across,
there's really easy
frequent access to space--
a lot more than people think.
Getting a launch,
I can get anybody
who wants to build a
CubeSat here launched
in six months to a year.
Not a problem.
I can get you a ride.
Very easy, frequent
access to space.
It gives you the ability to
basically rapidly respond
to a mission you want to do.
Right now, if you
do a mainline NASA
mission, or a mainline
NOAA weather mission,
or a DoD something, you're
starting on a three to five
year journey.
Hands down.
Easy.
And that's after you've
won the proposal.
It's going to take you three
to five years to actually put
together the science,
the spacecraft,
do all your design, all your
engineering, all your analysis,
go through the long
paperwork process that
will pretty much guarantee
you a successful mission.
But it's going to
take you five years.
You're biting a big hunk of
your life on any given mission.
If you just want to do some
quick and dirty analysis,
do some easy measurements,
do some rapid response-type
technology demonstrations,
this is tremendously much more
interesting.
Because we're talking
a cycle time of
say 18 to 36 months,
maybe 1 and 1/2
to 3 years of the
whole life cycle,
of coming up with the
idea, of flying it,
and then getting
the analysis back.
A lot quicker time cycle.
If you want to re-fly
it, we've done re-flights
in six months, where we've
designed, built it, flown it,
went, it didn't
work quite right,
changed a piece on
backup hardware,
rebuilt it again,
flown it again.
So we get a very rapid response.
And frankly, these are
relatively low-cost missions.
Now again, I work
for the government,
so relatively low cost
missions is just that.
It's on the order
of a million or two.
Sometimes $10 million for the
non-recurring engineering,
if you're designing
something for the first time.
For a university, though, they
can build a $50K to $100K.
Now that's a lot for
a university, I yield.
But they can build that
class of a spacecraft,
get it launched in somebody's
masters degree program,
get the data back, and
allow them to graduate.
That's pretty impressive.
And then you actually get
a whole class of people
out to graduate.
So what happened is,
NASA woke up to this.
Aviation Week, which is
one of those great trade
magazines that is
particular to my genre,
came out and said,
whoa, look out,
small satellites
doing more with less.
You notice this
small one right here
is one we built at NASA Ames.
We actually deployed it.
It was the first US
CubeSat deployed off
of the space station.
And we just did
that back in 2012.
October 4, 2012 we deployed it.
So what NASA's
doing is realizing,
this is an opportunity
to do different things
and different form
factors for less.
Now what's NASA's mission?
Just to rehash for
you people that
don't read our strategic
plan every day.
We're here to do science.
We're here to do
technology development.
We're here to do exploration
of the solar system.
And we're here to do, basically,
public outreach-- STEM, science
technology education,
engineering and math.
That's part of what our--
your tax dollars are doing.
That's why you're
paying me to do this.
It turns out that NASA
Ames, fortuitously, we
were the first one to
jump on this bandwagon,
in part because we're one of
the smaller research centers,
in part because we
had some people that
worked with the Stanford
and Cal Poly groups
that came up with this
standard, and in part
because we were just lucky.
Dumb luck.
So right now, we actually
lead NASA as an agency
in doing small and
nanosat missions.
And you'll see
that we're actually
getting into more and more
of it as time goes on.
One of the things you
can see from this chart,
it was a slow start.
And again, NASA
vernacular is, we all
have to come up
with a cool name.
And CubeSat semantics
means you have
to have "Sat" at the end of
your name, with apologies.
So we have GeneSat
and PharmaSat.
NanoSail-- there's a
sale involved, right?
OK.
You can kind of get all these,
TechEdSat, KickSat, EcAMSat.
We started out slow.
2006 was the first peer-reviewed
science publication satellite
that NASA did.
Now why does that matter?
NASA is a science and
engineering organization.
Our reason for existing is
promulgating good science
and engineering about
aerospace science,
space technology, et cetera.
What says that
something is of value
is having a published paper
in a peer-reviewed journal.
That's what matters.
For other people it's money.
For NASA, our
currency is citations.
Google Scholar's great.
Go find your citations.
That's what we live on.
So getting peer-reviewed,
publishable science
out of small CubeSats has
been a huge change for NASA.
And it's been a huge change for
the rest of the US government
space industry.
So we're doing a whole bunch--
you can see as time goes by,
we're paying out more
and more and more.
My organization is the
engineering organization
at NASA Ames.
And that's pretty much what
we spend our time doing.
This and larger
small satellites,
like LADEE and LCROSS
and other things
that have recently
been around the moon.
So let me tell you about
some of the different areas
of particular scientific
and engineering interests
that we're involved in, that are
making use of, again, this form
factor.
One of the things we work
on specifically at NASA Ames
is space biology.
Now what's the difference
between life sciences and space
biology?
OK.
Let me tell you.
When we say life
sciences, normally in NASA
we talk about how the astronauts
work and breathe and do
great stuff on the
International Space Station.
That's great.
That's kind of being
a medical doctor,
tracking them,
finding clinically
what makes them
good, how to manage
their allergies in
space, or whatever.
Space biology is actually
understanding the function
of how a biological system
operates in microgravity, zero
gravity and a high
radiation environment.
Again, why do we
care about that?
Well, guess what?
We are in the best
possible protective bubble
you could ever imagine
here on the planet Earth.
We've got this great
big rock underneath us
that gives us the gravity.
we've got this wonderful,
thick-- not that thick,
but relatively thick
atmospheric shell,
and we've got a molten
core of a planet that
is spinning to give us
this huge magnetic bubble,
so that we are
protected from all
the alpha and beta particles--
most of them, anyway--
that come flying out
of the sun and coming
from the cosmic
background radiation.
It turns out we're a great
place for life to exist.
Go look outside.
It's a beautiful
day, lots of life.
Do we know-- this is a question.
This is a quiz.
You can know the answer, right?
Do we know whether life
can exist elsewhere?
Do we know?
Anybody?
All right.
I'll leave it for the
people online to vote.
No, we don't know.
We suspect, absolutely.
But we do not know.
What we do know is that
we can do two things.
We can send people to the
moon for about seven days
and they won't
croak immediately.
And we can have six astronauts
live in orbit for about
a year long, and they
won't croak immediately.
Do we know that you
can put up a plant
and have it actually grow,
flower, fertilize the flower,
drop a seed, germinate,
and grow another plant?
Guess what?
We don't know.
We don't know that.
Do we know that we can send
out brewer's yeast out past
the Earth's magnetic bubble
and the yeast will actually
propagate-- grow, live,
die, and create all
that lovely yeasty smell
you get when you make bread.
Do we know that?
No, we don't know that.
We know so incredibly little
about how life will actually
exist outside of our
protective bubble.
This is why we do this.
So it turns out nanosats
were made for this.
CubeSats were made for this.
These are perfect.
We do these little
things, basically,
like, about this big.
Little, micro-fluidic systems,
little pumps, little wells,
little drip lines.
Of course we have
to adapt to the fact
that you're in
zero g or micro g.
And all of these systems are
custom-built to basically grow
different types of bacteria,
different types of yeast,
sea monkeys, you name it.
We've done it, and
we're doing it all.
Spores-- we have this little,
spinning, zero g, artificial
variable g disk that
does spore things.
We do e. coli stuff.
Great things,
fascinating science,
and because it's so
poorly understood,
a wonderful venue for us to
do exploration activities.
And it works out really well
that the CubeSats, which--
please don't take them
home; give them back to me--
are really a good venue
and a good opportunity
to do this science in.
One of the other
areas we work on
is we've got this really big,
expensive, fancy, multi-billion
dollar system up there
called Space Station.
We just gave it the thumbs-up
for another five years.
Probably it will go another
eight years after that.
So 2020 is the baseline.
We'll probably go to 2028.
And then what we do?
I don't know.
But we've got a big
space station up there.
Space station has
gone from being
the building you built
to now being the research
lab you're trying to stock.
So lots and lots of different
science activities-- material
science, biological
science, some of the stuff I
talked about before, life
science, all sorts of things.
Crystal growth, and then a whole
bunch of actual space science
are going on up there.
It turns out one
of the things that
is very hard to do right
now is either a, getting up
to space station, or b, getting
back from space station.
So when you get up
to space station,
everyone understands that.
That's hard.
You gotta get on a rocket.
Right now we're
buying Russian stuff.
We're hopefully going to
buy our own stuff soon.
Getting back-- how do you get
something back from space?
Right now, you basically
can take something
that's about the size
of these three chairs,
you cram three people in
them, and you give them
each about 10 kilos they
can hold onto their chest.
And that's how they come back.
That's how the
astronauts come back.
That's returned.
Return's what they
held in their hands.
So we're talking very
little volume returns.
And how often do they return?
They return about once every
six months, three to six months.
So if you want something
down from station,
you're not going to get it.
What do they do?
They flash freeze it.
They literally have
flash freezers up there.
They flash freeze it, or
they just put it to the side
and they wait.
So there's a driving need to
get what we call down mass.
How to get something down
from the space station?
Well, it turns out again,
for the mysteriously now lost
CubeSats, they're a great
form factor for that.
We've started doing deployments
off the International Space
Station, and doing what
we call an exobreak.
An exobreak is a fancy way of
saying Mary Poppins' umbrella.
Right?
You pop a shoot.
You increase the area, and
the very tenuous atmosphere
up there slows you much
more rapidly than if you
were a small,
relatively dense box.
OK?
So the idea is, we're
going through this process
to get what we call
down mass on demand.
It's not that sexy sounding,
but that's what it is.
So the idea is if astronaut
gets sick, something's going on,
they draw a vial of blood,
they pop it in the system,
they throw it overboard,
it falls down and lands
in your backyard.
They run into the hospital
and they check it out.
That's the vision.
That's kind of the
nominal vision.
It also goes for there's
different companies
that we've been talking to
for a long period of time
about doing biological testing,
growing crystallography
et cetera.
And one of the big
hangups has been, great.
Now you've got my stuff.
How do you get it down?
There's no safe way
for me to get my stuff
that I did on
space station down.
This is a way to address that.
Turns out there's some other
interesting applications
for that that I'll
talk about later.
But that's another area that
Ames is deeply involved in,
and doing a lot of work in.
This is a nice
picture, actually one
of my favorite pictures
of-- let's see, this one.
This one is TechEdSat, which
is the first US satellite that
was launched out of the
International Space Station.
We did it at Ames.
And in the background,
what you see,
actually, is the largest
structure NASA's built,
which is the International
Space Station.
That is one quarter
of one fourth
of one array that powers that
International Space Station.
So that's about a
football field square.
And that's a real picture.
It's not even good Photoshop.
After they deploy, they have
to float in front of the array.
So that's some of
NASA's smallest missions
with some of NASA's
largest missions.
Pretty cool looking stuff.
What we do, actually, is
there's a little airlock
on the Japanese side.
It's called the JEM module.
What a surprise.
Japanese Environmental
Module, or something.
And the Japanese allow
everybody to make use of it.
And so we load up
these deployers.
And the Japanese have
got a robotic arm,
grabs the deployer,
hangs it over the side
at a certain angle,
and then pops it out.
This was TechEdSat 3,
3P, that we actually
launched just this past fall,
which was the first 3U volume
3U volume, deployed from the
International Space Station.
And here I'm going to try-- OK.
That's it.
It's that exciting.
But that's all it really is.
There's not a gas canister,
there's not a rocket engine.
It's spring loaded.
They take the thing,
they cock it in,
it latches, they
put the lid down,
they put a deployment pin on it.
And that's where you go.
Here, there's two 3U dispensers.
What NanoRacks, the
company, has done
is they've taken 4 times 6.
No, 8 times 6.
They've taken 6U, linear-- so 3U
and then another 3U behind it.
And they've got 8 tubes.
And that actually is just
the right dimensions.
It can also sneak through
the Japanese module
and hang over the side and
they deploy them all at once.
The first deployment of that
was also this past fall.
There's a company in the Bay
Area called Planet Labs-- which
happens to be, in part, a
spin out from NASA Ames-- that
is deploying a whole
bunch of spacecraft
off the International
Space Station.
So we've already been
lapped, to some degree.
AUDIENCE: Was that
at real speed?
DAVE KORSMEYER:
That was real speed.
That's what it looks like.
It's just, pop and go.
And then, believe it or not,
you saw how fast it was going?
The rule for NASA is
you're not allowed
to turn on for 45
minutes after deployment
from station, because they
want you way the heck away
from station by the
time you turn on.
So they're really giving
you a very clear field.
But yeah, that's
as fast as it goes.
And you'll get pretty
far in 45 minutes.
So the other thing
we're doing is actually
the things in your hand.
So the lighter one, which
is again roaming around
somewhere-- take a look inside.
Some of you take a look inside.
Who's got that one?
Somebody put it down?
Come on, somebody.
Here.
Yeah.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Was there a Nexus One?
DAVE KORSMEYER: Yeah, exactly.
So I am here at Google, right?
So it turns out that one of our
guys had-- several of our guys,
actually-- had a clever idea.
And they said, you know, a
spacecraft isn't that complex.
You need a little
bit of a computation,
you need some data handling,
you need some calm capability,
you need a good
long-lived battery.
It needs to be compact
and good volume
constraints, be able to
handle good thermal regime,
and I don't know.
What do you think?
And one of them went,
hey-- and, I'm sorry,
this was pre-these things.
It was a BlackBerry.
And they said, hey, we
could fly a BlackBerry.
Why not just fly one of
these damn things, right?
And yes.
So we did.
We took it on.
You can see and hear, literally
there is a Nexus S on its side.
Actually, diagonal, because
that was-- it just so
happens to fit.
I don't know if you guys
did that deliberately.
And then whopping
load of batteries.
Because it turns out
International Space Station,
at the time, did not allow
us to fly lithium batteries.
So we had to go with NiCad.
So we had to strip
out the battery.
But literally, the screen's
in here and everything else.
And we've flown three
of these babies.
And, yeah, they work.
They work.
And what was the point?
It was a bit of a
technology stunt,
but it was to make the point
to the community and to NASA
that you really can make use of
consumer-grade, mass-produced
technologies and get a
decent behavior out of them.
So what we did with--
after we did this one,
is we did-- where's
the other one?
We did the PhoneSat 2.
So can you see a nexus in there?
No, you should not be able to.
And b, you should
notice that they're
solar cells, all around it.
What we actually did is, we
cracked the case on that one.
Took the screen off.
We don't need it.
Got down to the small board.
Actually had to float
the cell phone chip off,
because they really
didn't want that on
or connected in any
way, shape or form,
and then wired in the
rest of our avionics.
That worked relatively well.
Lessons learned?
There's a reason that a cell
phone board is in a cell phone
case, because those little
boards are the most fragile,
touchy things in the
friggin' world, right?
So that's a lesson learned.
They were just a pain the ass.
And where did we
get these Nexus S's?
Anybody have an idea?
We bought them
mass-produced from Google?
No.
We went to Best Buy.
And we got there early, and
when they're having a big sale.
And we bought a bunch of boxes.
That's exactly what we did.
So we flew a whole
bunch of PhoneSat 1's
we flew 2 Beta, which was we
had it half-assed put together
and we had a launch, so
we just flew what we had.
A 2.4 and a 2.5, don't ask
why we named them that way.
Some of them just went up.
The latest one just
went up in April.
We cracked the Android kernel,
did a lot of good, fun stuff
to make it all work together.
And we've used it also as the
core for some larger CubeSats.
It was functional
enough that it was like,
oh this kind of works.
We can make use out of this.
We started turning it
into additional CubeSats.
One of them is, you think these
were disruptive, as we came up,
we didn't come up with in idea.
A guy at Cornell came up with
these things called ChipSats.
So just when you think you're
safe, on the top is a PhoneSat.
On the bottom is a 3D-printed
deployment mechanism
that we built at NASA Ames.
And it's going to deploy
104 of these ChipSats, which
are 2 and 1/2 centimeters
by 2 and 1/2 centimeters
square, which has got
a little magnetometer
and a little gyroscope and a
little radio and a solar cell
and a microcontroller.
And it's going to
pop these babies out.
To what end, you say?
Well, it turns out that one
of the interesting things
about space and
atmospheric sciences
and basically
everything we do is
you don't want to take
a point measurement.
A singular point
measurement at one instance
in time at one location
will tell you one point.
What you want is you really
want a field measurement.
So if you watch geologists out
in the field or a biologist
or someone else,
they're are going
to take a point here,
note where they are,
go over here, take
a measurement,
note where they are.
They're going to take
a field measurement
to get a distribution of
a bunch of measurements
across a region.
How you do that in space?
Well, as you whip along in
a round orbit, that's great.
Another way is to deploy
a whole bunch of sensors.
This gives you as
a means to deploy
a bunch of very
interesting sensors.
And let's see if I
can do this again.
So when it's up there,
it'll get itself stabilized
after being deployed
from station.
A spring will release,
and these babies
will just pop out and
drive all the space
tracking people crazy.
And we really did.
We showed this to the--
it's called JSpOC,
the Joint Strategic Program
for whatever that tracks stuff.
They have no idea how they're
going to track stuff like that.
I mean, it really is hard.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: What is the
altitude of those launches?
DAVE KORSMEYER: About
425 to 450 kilometers.
AUDIENCE: Quite
a short lifetime.
DAVE KORSMEYER: It's
a very short lifetime.
So you've noted one thing.
How do we stop these
beautiful little toys
from being really
annoying space junk?
Number one is we
launch them real low.
So their lifetime is
measured sometimes in weeks,
at the longest maybe a year.
We have launched
ones that are higher,
up 650, 700, 800 kilometers.
They can last two,
three years up there.
So you have to make
sure then that you've
got tracking capability,
because they really
are so small it's hard
for the radar systems that
do track the stuff
to actually see them.
So we're actually putting little
transponders on them to squawk,
to tell you what's going on.
But this is a great system.
You can see, if you want to
measure the upper atmosphere,
these things literally flutter
down and squawk as they go.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So--
DAVE KORSMEYER: You'd like to
say that it doesn't, but it
does.
It really does.
We found out as an
example that the phones
are highly susceptible to
certain types of upsets.
And they're highly
susceptible to electrostatics
when they're out of their box.
That's why, again, they're in
these lovely little boxes that
are nicely shielded and
grounded and everything's good.
You take them out and they
become much more susceptible.
The thermal regimes
we're talking about here
are we're talking minus 100
degrees centigrade to positive
100 degrees centigrade.
These things are designed
really well, but not for that
every 90 minutes for the
entirety of their life.
It wears on them.
So while there's a lot
of good stuff out there,
I don't think you can
literally buy from Best Buy
and fly it and consider
that a functional model.
However, you can, with
some minor tweaks,
do some selections
to the stuff you buy,
test to find the very
robust components that you
want to make use
of, and fly those.
That's what we've
been able to do.
So here's just a
picture version of it,
in case the video didn't work.
So another thing we're
doing-- and again, we actually
used the elements of
the PhoneSat stuff.
We built a little
stability motor.
It's called attitude
determination control system,
but these are
little teeny motors
that you think when
a motor turns on,
it gives you a
little bit of torque.
You put three of
them perpendicular
and you get a torque that
control what position you're
in.
Instead of going out and buying
expensive control motors,
we actually got dental
motors, the type
that you get when
you get a root canal.
Those little motors
have a lot of torque,
and take a little bit of power
and spin up very, very quick.
We actually built a
swarm of satellites.
I'm a little bit
embarrassed to say
that this is the first actual
swarm that NASA's ever done.
And what's the
difference, in my mind,
between a swarm and
a constellation?
A constellation's just
a number, n number
of satellites that
are out there.
And they're all kind of
the same type of satellite.
That's easy.
It's a constellation.
You're a constellation
of people.
A swarm is when I
talk to you and you
make damn sure you
talk to everybody
and then report back to me.
That's a swarm.
So I'm treating a set
as if it's a unit.
What we're building
is-- what we've built,
actually, is a swarm.
And we're doing a bunch of,
basically, radio physics
measurements at the
upper atmosphere.
We've already built
them, and they're
launching later this fall.
Here's a picture in
our labs at Ames.
These are the EDSN.
Don't ask what it stands
for, but it's basically
the Edison Demonstration
of Space Networking.
And we built 8 that
we're going to fly.
We have four back-up units.
And then we built another
two, just for giggles.
We're going to throw off
the space station about
the same time just to
see how it all works.
But this is again, kind
of like that ChipSat model
I told you about, or that you
just saw in the little video,
except a little bit bigger.
We can have more power, we
can have more functionality,
we can have more
instrumentation.
AUDIENCE: What is the
yellow measuring tape for?
DAVE KORSMEYER: OK.
So the yellow
measuring tape is--
this was discovered by
the first students that
actually did CubeSats.
You need something
that is malleable,
because you want it to
fit in a finite box.
But you want to have a
way to get, I don't know,
an antenna out there.
It turns out that if you look at
what that yellow piece of metal
is, it's actually
a tape measure.
We went to Home Depot,
or OSH, take your pick,
or Lowe's, or whoever.
You buy a bunch of tape
measures, you cut them up.
They work phenomenally
well as antenna,
if you cut them
to the right size.
And then they wrap very closely
to the body of the spacecraft.
And they add a little bit of
extra twing when it pops out.
It imparts a little
torque as it goes.
So even though
we've replaced a lot
of the other
consumer-grade stuff,
the Home Depot tape
measures are really
hard to beat when it
comes to antennas.
They really are.
I mean, for certain
types, not for everything.
And so we just happened
to have, on this sat,
we have two antennas.
And part of it is because
we want to have one always
pointing to ground,
and one is going
to be pointing,
hopefully, to another one
of the satellites in the swarm.
OK.
How do you launch these
swarms, as an example?
Well, I showed you and I
should have really given you
a better picture of it.
There's these 3UP pod, what
they called them, dispensers.
I told you about that in
the NASA launch vehicles,
or any launch vehicle, you
tend to have a small satellite
on top of a big rocket,
with a lot of extra space.
Because you've
designed with margin.
We thought about it.
We came up with this idea.
We called it the nanosat
launch adapter system.
And really what it is, is it's
this fat disk that you can just
put underneath your satellite.
And it sits on the disk
and then the launch vehicle
sits underneath it.
And then within that disk,
you can kind of hollow it out,
and you can put these
dispensers, a whole bunch
on this side and a whole
bunch on the other side.
And I'll show you what
that actually looks like.
We call that the wafer,
and then the blue box.
That's the gold thing.
The wafer's the gold thing.
There's this little avionics
in the dispenser that
just fires a sequence
to open the doors when
it's appropriate.
And then the blue boxes
are the dispensers.
And this is called
the NLAS system.
We actually designed
this, and we released it,
open source so to
speak-- open design,
I guess is a better
model-- to any US vendor
that wants to make
or use these things,
because that's going to
increase the number of launches
that are available out there.
And they can create
a whole economic unit
of selling back and
forth to each other,
and we just benefit.
Because now we can go out and
buy a whole bunch of these,
and don't have to
build them ourselves.
So what we're doing is, for the
EDSN spacecraft in particular,
we get a launch on a new,
pseudo-commercial launch system
called Super Strypi that
AeroJet and Sandia National
Laboratories are
putting together.
It's actually going
to launch from Kauai.
Yes, I meant Hawaii but
the island of Kauai.
It's going to launch this fall.
We can fit four EDSNs,
which are 1 and a half U's.
So you've got the 1U
you passed around.
One and a half U's is 15
centimeters by 10 by 10.
So two one and a
halfs make three.
You can put four of
them in a 6U dispenser.
And we could put two
dispensers full of our stuff
on one side of the wafer,
and then the other side
is being used by
other groups that
are making use of
the launch vehicle.
And then there's a
mainline Hawaii sat-- what
a surprise-- on the top.
And that's going to launch
order November of this year.
And yes, I will go.
So what are the next
steps for NASA CubeSats?
I've talked a lot
about, basically, just
demonstrating the capability
that kind of is being
engendered by universities
and other groups already.
I talked about how we're doing
it for space biology, how we're
doing it for down mass from
International Space Station,
how we're doing it for
technical demonstrations.
Some of the other things--
I leave it to the community
to look at and just think
about-- but one of the things
we also do is we send
these lovely, deep space
interplanetary
spacecraft out there.
We send the Mars science
lab, the Curiosity Rover,
out to Mars a couple years ago.
Do you think we did the same
thing with that spacecraft
like we've done with every
other one, where we maybe
had a little extra volume and we
maybe had a little extra mass,
all held in Margin Yeah, we did.
And do you think on the
interplanetary transfer
stage that was throwing
Mars Rover at Mars
we also had additional
volume and additional mass?
Yeah, we did.
Do you think we sent
anything with it?
No, we didn't.
Why?
Politics, in large part, but
because people hadn't really
thought of it.
The standard hadn't
advanced enough.
The capabilities
hadn't advanced enough.
Now what we're talking about
is as you send these spacecraft
out, very expensive
spacecraft with a lot of money
and a lot of
intellectual capability
that are pretty much guaranteed
to work as best NASA can make
them, you send those babies out.
And with the remainder mass
and the remainder volume,
you send a bunch of little
crappy CubeSats out.
Not that crappy.
You send stuff out that's
probably going to work,
but you don't have to spend
so much money to guarantee it.
And you don't send one.
You spread your risk.
You send 10 or 15.
And what do you have them do?
You have them do things that
are unique to deep space
that you can't do elsewhere.
You have them measure the
space weather, which is really
how the sun behaves
outside of us,
our one viewpoint on the planet
Earth as we're moving around.
You have it check
with another set
of interesting
biological payloads.
How do they behave
in deep space?
We don't know.
We have no flipping an idea.
Lots of great
opportunities, and we're
launching stuff out
there every year or so.
We're doing a
mission called ARM.
I don't know if you guys
have heard about this.
This in play right now.
It's called the Asteroid
Redirect Mission.
This is a NASA
mission that's going
to go look for potentially
hazardous objects, PHOs.
We have to acronymize
everything,
which is code for a big
rock that may hit the earth.
And this is kind of
a cartoony version
of bag the asteroid and
move it somewhere else,
or give it a little
bit of a kick.
Again, you can spend a
couple billion dollars
on this baby to make
sure it damn near does
exactly what it's
supposed to do,
and does it to the
99th percentile.
And then you send a
small amount of money,
sending a fleet of smaller,
disposable but reliable
enough, very valuable
additional eyeballs
to see what else you're
doing from different venues
to measure the
broader environment
around this asteroid, perhaps
to measure who knows what
else you're doing in the area.
So this opens up a
whole different set
of characteristics.
For the down mass
device I talked about
from the International
Space Station,
this works out to be
a very interesting way
to get something all
the way to the surface,
maybe the surface
of Mars or Venus,
a bunch of very small things.
If you remember, we
spent a lot of money,
a lot of good money on
Curiosity, the big one,
and then on Spirit and
Opportunity back in 2003.
That was two and one.
Why don't we send 50, all
over the surface of Mars,
or all over the
surface of Venus?
Again, they're not
going to be as reliable.
But we're going to-- if
you lose three of the 50,
you still got 47, I hope.
So just to sum
up, NASA is really
trying to make use of this
disruptive model, this CubeSat
engineering capability
that, if you
go to any university right
now, frankly, a bunch
of high schools and,
believe it or not,
one elementary
school-- I don't know
how they do that--
they're building CubeSats.
They really are.
They're building CubeSats.
And we're going to fly them.
Ames turns out to be one of
NASA's particular centers
that's spending a lot of
energy, time, money, effort,
and intellectual
capital to make use
of these-- demonstrating
what can be done,
developing the technologies
to make it happen,
and basically managing
some of the programs that
allow all the other NASA
centers and universities to make
use of this form factor.
We're looking to partner
with a lot of universities,
non-profits, international
space agencies, and companies.
And we've done so.
Google bought a
company recently,
I believe called SkyBox.
They're not CubeSats,
but they're small sats.
They're microsats.
Same idea, that same
type of technology
but a little bit
larger form factor.
There's a lot of business
going on in this area.
NASA needs to
figure out where we
fit in this new world because
of this disruptive change.
I'm very excited about it.
I think there's a lot
of capability that
will be added by us
being able to do it.
I think software is
key here, because that
is what you can add is a
capability that weighs very,
very little but adds
great functionality.
But it's a whole
new world for us.
And Ames is on the
forefront of it.
Rest of NASA's coming along.
I thank you for your time.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: This is amazing.
I've been really
interested in this area.
I'm not a rocket
scientist, but a hobbyist.
Have you heard of Inner Orbital?
DAVE KORSMEYER: No, I haven't.
AUDIENCE: It's very similar
to what you presented today.
There is a CubeSat that you
can buy for about $10,000
to launch.
There's a TubeSat.
That's the lighter version
of it for about $8,000.
It's something that I'm
really interested in building
and launching in
January of 2015.
And I'm wondering, when
you said that someone could
get something like this
and get, essentially,
a quote unquote
"free ride," how free
and how cheap would
something like this be,
versus Inner Orbital?
DAVE KORSMEYER: So I don't
know what Inner Orbital does.
Do they provide launches?
Is that what they do?
AUDIENCE: Yes, a
kit and the launch.
DAVE KORSMEYER: So there are
a number of groups out there.
There's Spaceflight,
there's ISI, I know.
There's NanoRacks.
Sounds like there's
a whole bunch more.
And really, a lot of them are
using the same launch vehicles
and stuff NASA does.
All that we've done is we've
done a little bit of a bulk buy
idea, where we
know it's going up
and we put a dibs on
every launch vehicle
that some fraction
of that is ours.
And then we sponsor
groups to go up.
They have to be non-profit,
so educational or non-profit
or something like that.
We're not looking to support
a profit-making capability.
But it's really just
a proposal process.
You go to the NASA website, you
find CubeSat Launch Initiative.
Every six months
to nine months, we
release a call for proposals.
You write up a
proposal, you tell us
what you're going
to do, convince us
you actually can build
something that's of value,
and you saw our acceptance
rates on the order of 2/3.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying that
it's free if you get accepted?
DAVE KORSMEYER: It's
free if you get accepted.
There's worse things.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about the ARM mission
that you mentioned.
So we are also looking at using
6U CubeSats to actually impact
the asteroid as a
kinetic impactor.
So my question is that
much can we actually
deflect the asteroid
by using 6U CubeSats?
DAVE KORSMEYER: That's a zero.
But why would we do that?
Since I know where you work,
I can answer that question.
It's the same reason-- I don't
know if you guys remember back
in 2009, NASA Ames
had another mission
called LCROSS, Lunar Crater
Observation Sensing System.
Lovely acronym.
We smacked into the
south pole of the moon
into a deeply shadowed crater,
and blew up a bunch of junk.
Why did we blow up
a bunch of junk?
Because we couldn't see into
the permanently shadowed crater.
Permanent shadow.
So we had to pop
it out somewhere
where we could see it,
where it was illuminated,
and then we were able
to basically turn
our spectral analyzers
on it, and see what
was the chemical
composition of it.
That's why we do it.
We blast into it, so
something would pop off
that we could take a look at.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is, what
frequency do they,
the antennas, use?
DAVE KORSMEYER: OK.
So right now-- and
that's a great question,
because that's getting tricky.
These were started as
university activities.
So what we actually ended
up using was the ham band.
Anybody remember ham radio?
Ham radio operators
are all over the world
and are serious, their
own hacker community.
Turns out, you put a ham
radio transponder in space,
and pretty much anywhere
in the world, somebody's
going to be listening
if you tell them
what particular
frequency to listen to.
And they will find you,
and we just squawk packets,
and then they email
the packets back to us,
and we get the data.
It's a great model.
It's free.
The problem is, that
was specifically
only for amateur band,
amateur band operators.
Now that so many of these
things are going on,
and now that NASA's actually
starting to play in this game,
the amateur band
people are saying, hey,
it's getting too noisy
in our amateur band.
Please get your own
band to play with.
NASA uses a couple
bands, S, X, and KA band.
If you're not an RF
person, and I'm not,
I'll point you to an RF person.
But it's like 480
megahertz is the ham band.
I couldn't really tell
you what S, X, and KA are.
But we're looking for different
actual downlink capabilities
now, because of that.
AUDIENCE: There's an Open
Site glass on this thing.
Looks like there's a
little radical in there.
Is there a purpose for that?
DAVE KORSMEYER: I
couldn't tell you
without seeing exactly
what you're talking about.
You can show me afterwards.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE KORSMEYER: Oh yeah.
We did put corner reflectors.
You know what retro-reflectors
are, or corner reflectors?
They left them on the moon.
They're basically--
it's a box of mirrors.
And if you fire a light
at that box of mirrors,
it will bounce it
directly back to you.
Yeah.
And that is just a
mirror, is exactly right.
It's a little retro-reflector.
It's the idea that one
of the things you can do
is we're working with a group
in Australia that's got a laser.
It's a commercial grade,
big, whopping laser.
And they're lasing our satellite
and getting the bounce back.
That gives you
what's called range.
And you can also get what's
called range rate, which
is the rate of
change of that range.
And from that, you can get your
position really accurately,
down to a couple centimeters.
So that's the type of
stuff we're playing with.
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Is NASA
buying flights,
suborbital commercial flights
to launch these CubeSats?
DAVE KORSMEYER: Not solely
to launch the CubeSats.
So we have paid Space
X and Orbital Sciences
and Boeing and Lockheed
and all these guys
to launch stuff for us,
the US government has.
But we're launching
the big sats.
What we've done is we've--
as part of that contract,
we've claimed extra
volume and mass.
And with that, we're
launching the CubeSats.
Eventually, the launch
vehicle providers
are going to figure out
they can charge us for this.
They have not yet
figured that out.
Don't tell them.
AUDIENCE: And what about
suborbital flights [INAUDIBLE]
Spain's planning to launch--
DAVE KORSMEYER: There's a thing
called the Flight Opportunities
Program, which we will
fly anybody's junk.
Again, as long as you
propose, we fly our own junk
and we have to propose to that.
And they're all
suborbital flights.
So we fly out of the Mojave
space port, which takes you up
rather high, but doesn't
get you in orbit.
It's suborbital.
OK?
Thank you very much.
Appreciate the time.
Let me know if you want to chat.
[APPLAUSE]